NATIONAL GUARD, THE
ADMINISTRATION HOPES MORE AGENTS
CAN SPEND TIME ENFORCING THE LAW
AND DEPARTING THOSE WHO BREAK
IT.
>> Bret: WILLIAM, THANK YOU.
TONIGHT WE CONTINUE OUR REPORTS
FROM STATES IN WHICH REPUBLICANS
ARE TRYING TO FLIP U.S. SENATE
SEATS IN THE FALL MIDTERMS
COMING UP.
THIS EVENING, CORRESPONDENT
PETER DOOCY IS IN OHIO AS THE
G.O.P. CANDIDATES TRY TO ALIGN
THEIR POLITICAL CAREERS WITH
THOSE OF AN OUTSIDER PRESIDENT.
>> JUST A FEW BLOCKS AWAY FROM
THE ARENA WHERE A BUSINESSMAN
WITH NO POLITICAL EXPERIENCE
OFFICIALLY ACCEPTED THE
PRESIDENTIAL NOMINATION TWO
YEARS AGO, A BUSINESSMAN WITH NO
POLITICAL EXPERIENCE IS TRYING
TO END OR REPUBLICAN NOMINATION
FOR SENATOR.
>> HE'S GOING TO BLAZE THE TRAIL
AND WILL BE VERY EFFECTIVE AND
HE'S ACCOMPLISHED AN AWFUL LOT
FOR THE GOOD OF AMERICA.
I'D LIKE TO FOLLOW AND THUS WITH
STOPS.
>> IF INVESTMENT MAJOR MIKE
GIBBONS IS GOING TO UNSEAT
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR SHERROD
BROWN, HE'S GOT TO GET HIS NAME
OUT THERE.
>> WE PUT 65,000 MILES ON OUR
CAR.
>> THE OTHER REPUBLICAN,
CONGRESSMAN JIM RENACCI, SAID
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS THE REASON
HE'S RUNNING, TOO.
>> IT WAS A CALL FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> HE WAS INITIALLY RUNNING FOR
GOVERNOR BUT WHEN A HIGH-PROFILE
REPUBLICAN DROPPED OUT OF THE
SENATE RACE FOR FAMILY REASONS,
THE PRESIDENT NUDGED HIM TOWARD
THIS CONTEST.
>> I'VE SAID ALL ALONG.
A POOR KID FROM PENNSYLVANIA
GETS ASKED BY THE PRESIDENT AND
WHITE HOUSE TO HELP, I WILL DO
IT.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF RENACCI, AN EARLY
ENDORSER.
>> WE'LL BE BACK.
JIM, GET IN THERE AND FIGHT.
GET IN THERE AND FIGHT.
WE NEED YOU.
>> TRUMP BEAT CLINTON BY EIGHT
POINTS HERE.
THE PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR BROWN SAYS HE AGREES
WITH THE REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT
ONE MAJOR ISSUE IN THE STATE.
>> MY SUPPORT OF THE PRESIDENT'S
MOVE ON STEEL TARIFFS, I THINK
IT'S TIME WE DRAW A LINE ON
CHINESE MISBEHAVIOR AND CHINESE
GAMING THE SYSTEM.
>> RENACCI DELTA DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR IS IN FEAR.
>> THE ONE THING ABOUT
SENATOR BROWN, IT'S POLITICAL.
HE WILL HIDE WITH THE PRESIDENT
IS MUCH AS HE CAN.
YOU CAN ONLY HUG HIM ON WHAT SHE
DO THAT IS TARIFFS.
>> BROWN INSISTS NOT EVERYTHING
HAS TO BE PARTISAN.
>> VOTERS DON'T LOOK AT
LIBERALS, CONSERVATIVES, ANY
KIND OF SPECTRUM.
THEY LOOK AT EACH OF US.
YOU FIGHT FOR OUR PENSIONS,
HIGHER WAGES?
DO YOU FIGHT FOR TRADE
AGREEMENTS THAT MEAN JOBS IN
UNITED STATES?
>> THEN, THERE ARE THE VOTERS
LIKE MIKE GIBBONS, WHO LOOKED AT
IS MISSING.
>> I DECIDED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THE FACT THAT I WAS
THROWING THINGS IN MY TELEVISION
SET FOR THE LAST 25 YEARS.
>> WILL NAME YOU DIDN'T HEAR
JUST NOW, THAT OF THE REPUBLICAN
WON THE LAST BIG STATEWIDE
PRIMARY IN OHIO, JOHN KASICH.
HE IS STILL THE GOVERNOR BUT IS
MAKING MOVES TOWARDS A 20D
PRESIDENTIAL RUN AND IS NOT
SOMEONE THESE CANDIDATES ARE